I
what changed to make you play this year
now as for last year I chose not to play
in large part because of my standing in
the world at the time I was coming off a
very big victory and I felt the need to
take a break from trust for a bit
recharge my batteries per se tell us
about the risk-reward of a person who's
trying to compete with the elite
competition on the world stage and the
risk they run in their home US
Championship when it comes to rating
points um well for me it's not about the
rating anymore a lot has been made about
the fact that I'm within 10 points with
Bobby Fischer's all-time record is the
highest-ranking American but for me at
this point it's more about trying to win
tournaments and no matter where you come
from winning your national championship
is always very prestigious and for me
having won the US Championship twice
trying to win a third time perhaps one
day I can maybe when eight or more like
Fisher did back in the day um so for me
it's not about the rating it's about
winning ultimately and so you're
regarding yourself and got to be the
favourites again this year I I mean I
think we're the favorites God has won
the last two times when you look the
world rankings for the top 2 by quite a
wide margin but I mean that's that's why
you play chess why you play sports or
games in general is because if
everything was just based on the
seedings or who's supposed to be better
than you know what's the point in having
competition at all are there any players
whose ratings might Bulai their actual
ability and you think are actually
better especially the younger players I
think I mean all the young players are
dangerous certainly Robert has seized he
came very close to winning the year that
i won in 2009 on ray Robson as well he
sees that quite a run over the past
couple of years and I think the one may
be the one person who I think could be a
dark horse potentially would be
alejandro ramirez
who emigrated from Costa Rica to the US
and I mean any one of those three if
they have a good terms are able to play
consistently think they could all
compete for the title here why is it the
stronger players like a simple
round-robin format with the round-robin
format everyone s play everyone so
there's very very little luck involved
because you play the same players so you
can't really make excuses for complain
about your performance if you don't win
great thanks very much good luck dude
thank you